ausnahmezustand auch im heimischen
kinderspital in münchen eine der größten
kinderkliniken in deutschland in zeiten
der korona pandemie höchste
sicherheitsvorkehrungen bei jedem bei
ärzten pflegepersonal und eltern was
jetzt natürlich schon anders ist es dass
man halt kontrolliert wird am eingang
und nur noch eine besuchs person
zugelassen wird als mutter unterstütze
ich alles quasi was uns vorgegeben wir
den sicherheitsmaßnahmen hat diese
masken an was man eigentlich nie gedacht
hätte dass es bei uns auch mal kommt die
sorge dass der korona virus das
krankenhaus lahmlegen könnte ist groß
für das personal wie für die kleinen
patienten also wir haben hier viele
patienten mit krebserkrankungen mit ihm
und effekten und wir wissen alle noch
nicht so genau was passiert wenn diese
kinder mit dem kroner virus infiziert
werden
christoph kleines der ärztliche direktor
der klinik gemeinsam mit seinem team
versucht der normalität zu leben so weit
es irgendwie geht
kinder mit chronischen
lungenerkrankungen sind hier auf station
5 untergebracht schon in normalen zeiten
ist die belastung im haus für alle
immens personal und betten fehlen gelder
sowieso der alltag auf kante genäht
nicht außerplanmäßiges darf passieren
und jetzt das wissen alle nicht so genau
was jetzt auf uns zukommt und wir sind
schon auch alle in großer sorge
natürlich gar nicht verhehlen 14 zimmer
gibt es auf station 4 wurden jetzt
freigeräumt plus einem intensiv bett für
den fall der neben der ohnehin sehr
aufwendigen medizinischen behandlung und
betreuung dieser kinder geht es jetzt
verstärkt darum die angehörigen zu
beruhigen ich glaube dass wir alle
versuchen müssen ruhig zu bleiben und
natürlich macht es einem sorge und man
kann auch die sorge der eltern verstehen
denn niemand kann ja sagen ist diese
krankheit dieses neue krone wir uns
jetzt für diese chronisch kranken
patienten noch gefährlicher als für
andere ein kind auf station ist bereits
isoliert ob es ein grippe oder am corona
virus erkrankt ist ein testmuster
jetzt klären bei aller besonnenheit die
sorge vor den folgen der pandemie ist
permanent da tag und nacht genau
also macht schon mal auf das nebenan
liegt der kleine quentin der
sechsjährige aus thüringen wurde am
morgen operiert ja hatte in seinem hals
und wenn wir dies nicht regelmäßig
abtragen lassen dann würde das bedeuten
dass er irgendwann erstickt die
operation verlief gut durch die angst
vor dem virus sie herrscht auch hier bei
ihrem gerade jetzt nach der op frage ich
mich dann schon
es ist alles bunt wie es dann wie wir
dann damit umgehen sollte es uns treffen
doch daran mag kathrin weiß im moment
nicht denken quentin und sie sind froh
dass sie überhaupt zusammen sein können
denn durch corona ist das besuchsrecht
auch an dieser klinik extrem
eingeschränkt auf station eins werden
krebskranke patienten behandelt mit
medikamenten die das immunsystem der
kinder sprechen
viele eltern sind jetzt verängstigt weil
sie glauben dass ihre immungeschwächten
kinder leichter opfer des corona virus
werden könnten
mit verheerenden folgen so oberärztin
sibylle koletzko die eltern haben
besondere sorge um ihre kranken kinder
und wollen die medikamente absetzen
und wenn sie diese medikamente
vermindern oder gar absetzen dann
bringen sie ihre kinder wirklich in
gefahr
längst werden auch in der haunerschen
kinderklinik operationen die nicht akut
sind verschoben um für den notfall
vorbereitet zu sein
für die versorgung der welle an
patienten die sie erwarten die christoph
klein sagt eine welle von der er hofft
dass sie seine kleinen patienten nicht
mitreisen wird
wir machen in italien gibt es
kinderkliniken in denen die
intensivstationen die eigentlich für
kinder vorgehalten sind aufgrund der not
mit erwachsenen patienten belegt werden
müssen wir hoffen dass es nicht soweit
kommt er und sein team werden jedenfalls
alles tun um ihre kleinen patienten
weiterhin medizinisch gut zu versorgen